alors moi pourquoi je viens témoigner
aujourd'hui mon affaire elle a été
médiatisé par le journal le monde par le
parisien il ya même le magazine marianne
qui a sorti la sphère dans la presse ils
ont eu la procédure et ils ont ils ont
effectivement raconter non les tapis qui
avait des faux en écriture phase
extraordinaire je rentre à soir chez moi
je vais essayer de faire vite je rentre
un soir chez moi
le 19 août 2019 je rentre à la maison et
je descend l'avenue de clichy donc la
venue de sa part hissé les voiles à et
j'habite pas très loin du commissariat
du 17e dix septième la sphère michel est
clair donc je rentre et je j'arrive à
hauteur de la rue legendre a
effectivement je je je vois une rixe
j'étais au téléphone avec ma mère et la
rixe était tellement importante les gens
criaient que ma mère me dis qu'est ce
qui se passe je lui dis n'en sais rien
c'est des gens qui se battent dans la
rue et ma mère me dit à l'ats le réflexe
à me dit mais de rentrer à la maison
rentrer en dessous de suite donc je me
façon j'étais fatigué comme je dis oui
je les rentre et je raccroche et par
enfin je ne sais pas comment mais oui
voilà avant de rentrer j'avais besoin de
me rassurer qu'ils avaient assez de gens
dans la rue dans la rue deux jambes pour
au cas où s'il se passait quelque chose
de vraiment grave estime que qu'ils
appellent pour pour qu'ils aient assez
de gens qui appellent la police en fait
et au moment où je tourne la tête là en
fait vu que j'étais plus au téléphone
j'étais concentré avec 6 10 et toutes
les personnes qui étaient dans la rue
legendre aussi bien aux balcons que sur
la chaussée criaient en fait s'il est en
train de crier ne fait pas ça ne fait
pas ça et il disait ça à une désagréable
en fait j'avais y avait une victime au
sol et trois agresseurs il y avait deux
de deux hommes et une femme est là elle
est en fait les gens crier ne fait pas
cinq sets face à la femme qui avait le
casque de moto intégral un casque de
moto intégral à tête
elle avait le casque de moto intégral à
la tête excusez moi je vais vous mi mai
ce qui s'est passé parce que c'était
c'est assez virulent elle avait le
casque de moto comme ça au dessus de la
tête et elle se met lé les gens malgré
que les gens lui disent me faites pas ça
ne fait pas ça c'était comme s'il l'a
encouragé pour lui dire à lui dire allez
vas-y vas-y vas-y et à la scène ce coup
de casque de moto sur la tête
donc moi j'étais tellement choqué qui a
l'a dit
qui peut au sol c'était une femme en
avant je double je et où j'étais jeune
ça j'ai je savais pas si c'était un
homme ou une femme ou wav là bref
et quand je vois ça ni une ni deux je
fais quoi je fais le 17 sur mon portable
je traverse l'avenue clichy je rentre
dans la rue legendre mon coeur battait
fort parce que je me suis dit mais
qu'est ce que je vais qu'est ce que je
vais trouver est ce que la femme mais
qui est au sol la victime et aux salles
que ce soit un homme ou une femme peu
importe à ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle
saigne ce qui est ce qu'on va devoir
appeler le les pompiers 1
certainement donc j'avance plus
j'avançais plus je voyais que la femme
qui était au sol elles étaient de très
faible corpulence et j'arrive à
identifier effectivement que c'est une
femme mais elle était tellement au micro
je suis excusé moi et et puis là ça a
été plus fort que moi
malgré les gens sur la chaussée fait les
gens qui avaient sur la chaussée je ne
leur jette pas la pierre je vais pas
leur dire oui l'on y est je sais très
bien que beaucoup de gens ce soir-là
mois que la police parce que la police
au téléphone après me l'a confirmé
mais moi ça a été plus fort que moi je
quand j'avais 20 ans je vois ça je j'ai
pas pensé au danger que je pouvais moi à
voir j'avance et je le redis je jouais
les trois agresseurs jeudi mais sinon je
dise pas possible vous pouvez pas vous
pouvez pas vous mettre à trois sur une
personne et la l'agresseur le plus
virulent smam criaient m'a cassé ma
vitrine judith judy peu importe quoi
qu'elle ait pu faire vous vous êtes
décrédibilisés tout simplement juste
donc moi le but c'était pas de rentrer
dans ce qui se passait c'était de gagner
du temps le temps que la police arrive
parce que pour moi la police est elle la
seule solution c'est à la police de
venir dominer ce qui se passait qu'est
ce que c'est parce que qu'est-ce qui se
passera la suite le temps qu en dessous
- enfin un seul le grand soulagement
j'ai enfin la police au téléphone parce
que vous savez très bien quand on fait
le 17 mai quand la police arrive
le bolide identifie donc les agresseurs
les témoins et la victime pour une fois
y avait tout le monde est le pendant
qu'un des policiers prenaient nos
coordonnées pour éventuellement un
témoignage ou autre il ya l'agresseur le
plus virulent qui se met sur la chaussée
et il se met à nous menacer dire oui toi
là-bas attention tu as rien mais tu dis
rien t'as rien vu comme ça devant le
policier dont fois je me dis bon il
aggrave son cas la police va intervenir
moins bien mais déçu fait la police ne
dit rien la police intervient pas est ce
que je vous dis tous les témoins que
j'ai eus témoignages écrits 1 avec
l'attestation et qui ont même été
entendus
par là par la section déontologie à la
préfecture de paris disent tous la même
chose donc la police intervient pas eh
bah ça donne du courage à cet agresseur
l'a l'agressant le plus virulent et
continue ils menacent encore la même
chose mais un peu plus de façon plus
énergique plus vite plus virulente donc
là moi je regarde le policier qui prend
nos coordonnées je lui dis mais excusez
moi je lui dis mais je je vous avais
entendu ce qui s'est passé et là le
policier me me regarde la musique non
non alors que tout le monde avait
entendu
moi je pense après à ma sécurité à moi
hein donc je dis aux policiers julie
excusez-moi judy attaque je dis attendez
je reviens là le policier aurait pu me
dire non non vous restez ici et le jeu
et je me serais exécuté voilà parce que
j'ai un profond respect pour pour
l'uniforme et il est le policier ne me
dit rien donc j'avance un petit peu
juste un petit peu sur la chaussée il y
avait la police entre nous et
j'interpelle l'agresseur le plus
virulent jute excusez moi monsieur
excusez moi juste pour vous dire on a
juste appelé la police pour papier de
mort sur la chaussée c'est tout j'avais
envie de faire passer j'étais obligé moi
pour ma sécurité à moi parce que
j'habitais le quartier j'habite le
quartier depuis 2004 et j'apprends que
cet agresseur le plus virulent qui n'a
pas peur visiblement de la police déjà
les parcs de moi de me retrouver nez à
nez un jour avec lui voilà donc j'avais
besoin de lui faire passer le message
que voilà effectivement d'appeler la
police mais voilà deux témoignages et
après élevé sept agresseurs me dit m'a
dit oui je sais je sais madame vous êtes
en train de me dire ne tapez pas la dame
ne tapez pas la dame est là il ya un
policier de la bac qui arrivent et qui
se met à me mettre la main sur le la sur
les poules y à me pousser les bains
preneur excusez moi aime pousser et il
me dit vous allez sur toi et moi je lui
dis quoi je dis oui monsieur l'agent je
vais sur un trottoir comme ça tout en
reculant et envoie tout sur la vidéo la
vidéo qui est sur la sellette l'ail et
vous tapez la lan violences policières
vous à l'e3 la vidéo et jeux tout en
reculant je lui dis oui oui monsieur
l'agent jeu je m'exécute je vais sur un
trottoir et judy par contre julie
excusez moi je dis vous avez rien dit
quand on s'est fait menacer par par le
par l'agresseur est là il dit mais j'en
ai rien à [ __ ]
donc moi je ne cherche pas pilot
épiloguer avec tout ce que j'ai vu donc
je cherche qu'à rentrer chez moi et donc
je lui dis je dis pas écouté je dis bah
je veux excuser moi je dis moi je rentre
chez moi et là au moment où je lui dis
je rentre chez moi on voit dans la vidéo
il me met la main donc ici là ils
essaient de rattraper le coup
donc ici c'est très sensible donc il
m'est
ici l'eau sur le coup d'envoi le réflexe
que j'essaie de passer ma main comme ça
je lui dis d'ailleurs la vidéo que vous
regardez dans ce moment c'est la vidéo
du témoin on a eu de la chance d'avoir
cette vidéo là sinon voilà et donc je
met justement mais comme ça je lui dit
excusez moi je dis non ça va pas en quoi
je lui dis c'est moi qui a appelé la
police
et là il supporte pas en fait que je
veux mettre ma main comme ça et il
m'attrape par le coup un niveau pas me
lâcher et il me traîne sur quelques
mètres et tout le monde crie on entend
dans la vidéo tout le monde crie mais la
chaîne a elle appelé la police à l'ats
voulu aider la victime la chaîne al
ajilat il veut rien entendre et moi je
le supplie de me lâcher il veut rien
entendre il m'a même il a été jusqu'à me
dire un pardonnez moi je vais être
vulgaire il a acquis la quasi là il a
été jusqu'à me dire oui mais tu vas la
fermer ta gueule alors que je demandais
juste à steam lâche parce que je
n'arrivais pas à respirer
c'est tout simplement donc là arriva au
bout d'un moment quand vous arrivez plus
à respirer à respirer un sabot est un
agent de police c'est obligé de passer
votre en excusons vous êtes obligés de
passer votre de passer votre doigt pour
pouvoir desserrer l'étau donc je passe
justement pouces comme ça pour desserrer
l'étau là il me donne un violent coup de
pied dans le tibia et il me plaque sur
le mur qui est juste derrière et donc
tout le monde crie la victime
la victime qui était sur le trottoir
allez viens même à mon secours quand
elle quand elle le voit qui lucky que
qui me donne le coup de pied sur le
tibia et voilà c'est tout ce que vous
avez et oui après par la suite la police
me fait croire qu'ils ont besoin de la
tour magne âge parce que on juste
pourquoi donc vous êtes en train de dire
donc que là mais la personne qui était
agressé au départ s'est séparé qui sait
des policiers qui l'ont refusé non
c'était c'était là la police vous êtes
fait agresser donc par un policier de la
bac à l'assaut policier la très belle
cascade bercy et il est important de
dire non mais vous avez raison et donc
je ne sais mais pourquoi c'est pourquoi
c'est super important là ce que je vais
vous dire c'est très grave ce qui s'est
passé par la suisse ils m'ont fait
croire qu'ils avaient besoin de mon
témoignage pour la première rixe devenir
un écho au commissariat
arrivé au commissariat il y avait les
pompiers parce que j'avais une énorme
basse au niveau du tibia pentues du
pompier pensais même que c'était casse
est arrivé au commissariat il nous faut
il nous faut attendre longtemps ils
essaient de me faire signer un papier
sans que je puisse voir la première page
ils me disent allez-y signé signé vous
allez à l'hôpital heureusement que j'ai
tenu à avoir la première page avait
marqué violences en marge avait marqué
les violences
en terre sur personne dépositaire de
l'autorité publique c'est extraordinaire
et quand je jouais là j'étais
complètement désemparés parce que y
imaginez ce que je venais de vivre un
jeu passe donc là je passe en un instant
votre vie a basculé en faites vous
passer de deux témoins à victimes et de
victimes on veut vous faire que ça
prendrait ça ça faisait comme moi je
m'attendais au commissariat je me suis
dit bon ils comprendront ils vont
prendre mon témoignage et le policier va
certainement venir vouloir s'expliquer
avec moi il s'est excusé moi je peux
tout entendre j'ai des amis dans la
police et oui j'en ai beaucoup d'amis
dans la police dans l'armée et enfin je
vais je veux dire gg aussi on a des amis
depuis mon depuis ma plus tendre enfance
à la gendarmerie
là on va vous allez continuez messieurs
avec eric naulleau oui je vous en prie
la dernière chose que je voulais dire
c'est que par la suite
donc ils m'ont mis après après le
l'hôpital ils m'ont placé en garde à vue
garde à vue et après le lendemain ils
font une réquisition judiciaire pour
récupérer la vidéo de l'agglomération et
la vidéo de l'agglomération tenez vous
bien il faut une première est qu'ils
n'ont atteint de 30 minutes sur la vidéo
30 minutes et quand il voit tous les
faits tout ce qui se passe il aurait pu
dire oui ça y est c'est bon on a fait
une grossière erreur il va falloir qu'on
s'excuse auprès de madame voilà qu'on
essaie d'arranger les choses non la
journée va passer en fin de journée à
18h il faut une deuxième réquisition
judiciaire et il demande que 20 20 ou 25
secondes et c'est sur 25 25 secondes que
je vais me retrouver devant le tribunal
de l'a28 devant la 28e chambre le
tribunal correctionnel tgi de paris
si je n'étais pas tombé sur madame agnès
herzog la présidente de la 28e chambre
qui a voulu décortiquer quand elle a vu
la vidéo du témoin et je remercie les
journalistes qui font un travail
exceptionnel parce que sans le l'article
du journal le monde et du nouvel obs
jamais 7 - ce témoin de rappeler mon
avocat maître d'aller david de curial
qui a été aussi sensas sensationnel amon
à mes côtés parce qu'il m'a beaucoup
soutenu on aurait des 107 vidéo
sans cette vidéo écoutez moi bien ma vie
elle aurait basculé et je me serais
retrouvé mes quatre casiers judiciaires
- la grande militante associatif
moi qui me bats qui est protégé tout le
temps à chaque jour doit quelque chose
sur la police tout le temps tout le
temps je parle je dis non il faut pas
mettre tout le monde dans le même sac
c'est pas possible on veut pas mettre
tout le monde dans le même sac et là
vous vous retrouvez en un instant on
peut vous faire basculer de l'autre côté
votre vie a basculé non moi je peux pas
donc effectivement j'ai réfléchi à deux
fois avant de faire les vidéos que j'ai
fait pour le parisien et pour combiner
mais là je
tous les témoins tout ce qui est tous
ceux qui ont été victimes de violences
policières à doivent parler j'adore
parler moi je vous le dit et là on a
déposé plainte le contre le policier
elle a été classée sans suite il a fallu
qu'on fasse une citation directe
donc on va voir ce qui va se passer en
début d'année au moins pour le faux
usage de faux
je vous rappelle qu'ils ont écrit sur
les pv ils ont fait défaut ils ont ils
côtoient je suis pour quand je suis
passé devant le policier du gipn vous
savez ce qu'il a dit il m'a dit mais
c'est pas possible
l'asnl à la réquisition judiciaire qui
tue quand il la faut qu'ils en fassent
une ou dix il doit y avoir tous les
scellés il a payé il m'a dit comment
situez commencé c'est que ça n'allait
pas dans les scellés dont qui voyez bien
que le trafic qu'ils ont fait et pépé le
policier me dit il prend ma plainte le
16 juillet pour le faux usage de faux
abus d'autorité et dénonciation
calomnieuse le 16 juillet dernier
message juillet dernier et le helley le
policier me dis je vais il m'a dit je
vais je vais en vacances demain
il m'a dit mais l'idée que je reviens ou
le début août il m'a dit je fais mon
enquête le 3 août le procureur monsieur
etienne de barre il a classé sans suite
le procureur en 18 jours un temps record
sans enquête et même lui il a fait un
faux même lui la fin à un faux en
écriture puisqu'il écrit dans le
classement sans suite
il ose écrire il ose écrire les éléments
de l'enquète n'ont pas permis qu'elle
enquête
j'ai appelé après le policier du gipn il
lui et c'est voulu aussi été surpris que
ça soit classée sans suite donc moi je
je je dis je vous le dis et je le dis à
monsieur messier en face depuis tout à
l'heure je vous entends dire certaines
choses mais c'est faux c'est faux moi je
n'ai pas de casier judiciaire
je vous le voyez je suis le jeu j'ai une
bonne éducation je veux dire j'ai fait
des études
je suis dans le milieu et de notes dans
le milieu associatif et j'ai fait
beaucoup de choses dans ma vie dont je
dans ma vie dont je suis fier je
méritais pas ça
j'ai juste voulu secourir une victime
c'est tout ce que je justifie pas ce
monsieur messier à tous ceux qui ont
témoigné qu'ils ont fait les témoignages
et écrit avec les identités qui n'ont
pas eu de peur de témoigner alors qu'ils
habitent en face de la boutique de
souliers de ceux de cet agresseur 1 ils
me l'ont tous dit il mon dit non on
témoigne parce que nous aussi on allait
descendre
donc si vous êtes parent il avoue ça
aurait pu nous arriver à nous vous
n'avez pas eu de vidéos se seraient
passées autrement
bah oui parce que vous savez très bien
que et je pense que madrid
parce que m garrido je pense que vous
allez d'accord avec moi mais vous savez
très bien qu'on peut on écarter une
attestation pour x raisons même si là il
y avait une dizaine d'associations
je suis sûre et certaine cette vidéo
elle a eu un impact
vous savez madame agnès herzog comme tu
allais quand elle a vu la vidéo elle a
vu la vidéo de la préfecture donc vain
je vous ai dit 25 secondes à on la voit
mais deux sur le l'article de marianne
on voit tout et sur l'autre vidéo son et
image et la présidente de la 28e chambre
daniel sérieux mais c'est une femme
exceptionnelle
je dois remercier le policier qui ont
connu une fille nés ou pas ouais c'est
ça non non n'y a pas tant que ça
qu'est ce qu'on s'en suit est ce mon
avocat maître david turrel que je
remercie il élit les ccc lui aussi c'est
un homme exceptionnel
il est il et hilali jalil a fait une
citation directe 6 3 2 contre estimant
que j'allais rester avec nous se passe
en france